welcome to this video and he's not now
is playing I played much of the kirkham
lately that's very let's play play some
French and can only play Knight f6 if I
play this oh ok ok I'm not the most
exciting line ever but then at least
them it looks like his maybe trying to
Castle long ok well at least if he
castles long i have b 5 a-5 he needs to
think about that if you really wants to
do it night to e4 night to reform there
should be seven I 2258
yeah but it's a beast on what can you do
it's not good so maybe maybe play the
some classical oh he really he really is
canceling a castle English long
interesting I didn't really have
expected that by now with the a3 ok
let's castle of course he's got some
ideas as well no 94 not probably not
yeah he really wants to make sure that I
don't put anything on them on 85 do you
want to play a five himself but it looks
a bit clumsy am so mad sir let's see if
I can open up some lines here with a
five is before I reckon that the best
you can do when yo is this at the shirt
short notice f5 and take here but it
takes a while until I met it to say the
least I mean it's it's it's not far away
from from threaten um okay so
night 94 is not really good I could try
to exchange on a six that's also what's
a bit stupid
okay let's um I'm not committed to two
playing for made here this is also not
bad at all night f2 and queen e 393 does
various ideas am yeah I could take edge
to it sir but still like I really could
do that yeah it's it's no threat really
I think
yeah okay the Queen trade oops this is
surprising the Queen trade looks
basically am like a loss to me so at
least with good technical play i should
i should be able to to win this and I'm
not Oh surprising I'm not too much down
long time night before orgy you forever
g5s lot bed I wouldn't mind you I'm not
too much should I take it almighty forms
of both not bad I don't want the night
to go to e5 for cam let's let's just
grab that
yeah first first make sure do i get the
king I know this is a good move I should
isolate the default corn this is a good
one 96 coming and then he needs to
defend the default porn and he cannot do
this with a pawn I mean he can but this
also would be a good structure see pawn
moves and I take it yeah exactly now
he's got get the service those
weaknesses the King before I can play 97
oh this I didn't really expect okay
let's activate now at some point the
Knights need to take material Jeff
want to go to d 693 maybe it's not
completely trivial you know you don't
really don't really want to play h5 so
quickly but probably am I need to do it
jack
check
check
yeah not much shine not much you can do
yeah yeah now we can try to play this on
time of course so quite I think the idea
to lose this game is quite strange
actually but of course with no
incremented it can happen well this is
nice that she actually didn't try to
play this on time I stopped playing time
he would win on time all right yeah this
is fairly easy technical win but still I
managed to to screw it up I'm surprised
ready this should be really easy now two
against three porn islands yeah why did
I'm did I screw this up hmm maybe the
care maybe I need to activate the King
first or check
I can just plain idea for g2g too yeah
sometimes the the explanation is really
easy just just win the the bloody porn
and again I can win the pond why don't I
c9f to check strange okay at least that
that explains why he got God active all
of a sudden he couldn't really do it I
just afraid to take the phone alright
thanks for watching